chaos on Capitol Hill Democrats and
protesters turning the Brett Kavanaugh
hearing into a three-ring circus
President Trump
reacting minutes ago on Twitter saying
the Brett Kavanaugh hearings for the
future Justice of the Supreme Court are
truly a display of how mean angry and
despicable the other side is they will
say anything and are only looking to
inflict pain and embarrassment to one of
the most highly renowned jurists to ever
appear before Congress so sad to see
Senate Dems hijacking the hearing just
seconds into it over a dispute about the
release of the Supreme Court nominees
records claiming they haven't had enough
time to go over them 4,000 pages of
documents that we have not had an
opportunity to review or read or analyze
you are you're out of order I'll proceed
we cannot possibly move forward mr.
chairman if we cannot be recognized I
move to adjourn mr. Chairman I move to
adjourn we have been denied real access
to the documents we need what is the
rush what are we trying to hide by not
having the documents out front it is
regular order for us to receive all the
documents
to receive all the documents that this
committee is entitled to Wow the RNC
calculating Democrats interrupted over
60 times and when they weren't doing
that Capitol Hill police arrested
roughly two dozen demonstrators for
rowdy disruptions like this Alexander
Hamilton wrote in the Federalist Papers
mr. chairman could I um pause there
until the room is cleared surely I was
[Music]
one of the most distinguished judges mr.
Chairman I think we ought to have this
let's bring in red bear and Dana from
Washington DC near all the action on
Capitol Hill
all right Bret we'll begin with you
we're hearing that the Senate Democrats
coordinated the disruption with some of
these protesters who I believe are from
the women's March mostly as you remember
what does that tell you about the level
of energy on the left with regard to
this Cavanaugh here listen they have not
done a great job galvanizing the
opposition and they know as it stands
right now that Democrats don't have the
votes to block this nominee if as
expected all the Republicans stand firm
and they vote for him and Democrats even
there are a few red state Democrats who
are considering you know voting for him
so they know that they had the votes
don't go on their way we know for a fact
they coordinated as far as the the
beginning of the opposition to say they
didn't needed more time a number of
different written pre-written statements
that you could see all the senators
reading as for the the protesters that
now is a normal thing that we have seen
really for the past 31 years since
Robert Bork nomination yeah and it
usually just happens with the Democrats
I don't know how they think that can
galvanize any independence but I guess
they're not trying to galvanize any
independence it's just the left-wing
base they need to placate we'll begin
with some questions and go around the
table Greg Gutfeld has a question for
you Brett hi Brett good to see you
good see I have a theory that most of
these hearings are like kids playing
soccer
there's just no score until the end and
then you settle it with like penalty
kicks nothing matters we know what the
votes gonna be we know how this ends why
don't they just adjourn and call for a
floor vote why do we keep doing this
kabuki clown show it's a rolling tantrum
we know that the people aren't going to
vote for him aren't gonna vote for him
we know the people are gonna vote for
vote when we know that now why are we
wasting so much time and energy on this
garbage because advise and consent is
basically their role they need to go
through the confirmation hearing they
need to ask the nominee questions about
his record you're right I mean even the
Democrats on the committee Cory Booker
and others conceded they were on no vote
weeks ago as far as getting more
documents to be transparent they've
already made up their decision they're
saying it is for the benefit of the
American people I see what you're saying
it's the way that they go through these
things I think one of the most
interesting speeches today was Ben Sasse
senator Ben Sasse who basically gave a
schoolhouse rock of the three branches
of government and the role that the
legislature is supposed to play article
1 of the Constitution and he's going to
be on the show tonight we're gonna ask
him about all that nice plug all right
when tuning in there and I believe we
have Dana Perino up and ready there she
is Dana from Washington DC how are you I
just had a quick question you know I
know you have a lot of inside sources
over there on the Capitol Hill what are
you hearing who do you feel one do the
Republicans think they had a good day or
the Democrats think because they created
all this drama did the Democrats feel
like they scored big at today's hearing
well I think the Republicans think that
they are playing a longer game so
they're looking right now and the reason
we have these hearings is as Brett said
it's just part of our process but if
you're a Republican and you're in the
Trump White House you're thinking well
four days of a hearing for a lifetime
appointment to the Supreme Court not so
bad I don't I think the Democrats might
have thought they got some shots in
today but they're kind of ephemeral I
would say this the Democrats spent a ton
of time today talking about
and in my experience if you're talking
about process that probably means you
don't have much else to go on and it
doesn't last very long because as soon
as we get into the hearing tomorrow
where you have the nominee finally
answering questions that are of
hopefully of substance then the process
questions will probably fade away the
Democrats have decided that they had to
do something to show that their base
that they're willing to fight they've
had nine weeks they've not come up with
a coherent long lasting argument against
Brett Kavanaugh they're just against him
overall I did think it was interesting
Jesse that the Democrats never seem to
be mad at Senator Harry Reid who made
the decision to break those protocols
years ago and that has led to this
moment where you only need 51 votes to
confirm a Supreme Court nominee the
Democrats best hope would be to try to
win more elections of course but what
they did today Jesse is they put
Democrat senators in red states those
ones who are up for re-election in a
real bind they already have it tough
this does not make it easier for them
Indiana West Virginia Missouri even all
red states that those senators could be
in tough trouble
Jedidiah is here in your seat Danna and
she's trying to hold up the Perino for
it over here at least your feet will
touch the floor fairly fairly almost I
do have the pillow though you know I
wanted to ask you that one of the
funniest things to me today was that
Democrats were trying to paint it like
they didn't have enough information to
make the decision like oh we just had a
little bit more information about him it
might sway the tide and we might support
him while you have Cory Booker while
he's saying those things sending out
fundraising emails saying stop Cavanaugh
and I'm sure that was going for it for
many Democrats across the board why is
this a strategy they use everybody knows
that these Democrats already on record
saying they're not going to support him
why go this route well one is that if
you are running for election in 2020 as
a possible presidential candidate then
you want to make sure that you're on a
record they also did it because Chuck
Schumer yesterday apparently held a
conference call where they organized
this sort of protest against Grassley
based on the process points but also you
know to be fair what senator Booker is
saying is that
I've already decided I'm not going to
vote for you but it is my duty to
uncover everything I can so that my
constituents have full information I get
I agree with you it is futile if you're
already going to vote against him and I
thought at the beginning when they
started that that Senator Grassley could
have said Oh senator Hirono you are
open-minded on Brett Kavanaugh that's
pretty what could we do to help you get
to a yes and she would have said there's
nothing you know what's interesting is
is certainly senator Grassley at first
on Twitter and elsewhere was getting a
lot of grief were not like throwing down
the gavel and saying all right that's
enough just move forward his Mo was to
let everybody air out their grievances
let it play out and then move on and
frankly he got control at least of the
Democrats after they kind of aired out
all that they were going to do and there
was an interesting moment there I
believe it was a father of one of the
parklands school shooters his name the
dad Fred Guttenberg and there's an image
that's going around the internet of when
Fred tried to approach the nominee and
tried to shake his hand afterwards and
it's being played in the media as the
nominee rejecting the handshake of a
parkland
shooting victim but if you see the video
and I want you guys to react to that it
was a chaotic quick moment and the video
shows Kavanaugh kind of being confused
and having someone come after him with
an extended hand and you know the
hearing had been very rowdy all day and
you know security kind of stepped in and
he moved into a different direction this
now this gentleman who we have a you
know great empathy for because he lost
his son is is on CNN and MSNBC tonight
is this a moment you think that you know
is going to make an impact with these
with these hearings and in the rest of
the country I'll go first if that's okay
Brett so I served as I saw that posted I
thought they're gonna try to make a
really big deal out of this I know Brett
Kavanaugh personally and actually if you
look at the character witnesses from
both sides of the aisle that have spoken
about what a great man he is but this is
not something that Brett Kavanaugh would
do if under normal circumstances
I don't think he knew what was happening
you're right Jessie if you're watching
the hearing this morning every two
minutes there was another yell and a
scream and a protester his children had
to be escorted out during that period
and when they go to take the first break
if he's been sitting there for three
hours his back is turned the man comes
up to him I have no doubt in my mind
that had he known he would have been
willing to shake his hand but when the
security is like let's go because you
don't know what is happening in the room
I have to give him the benefit of the
doubt
but I would not underestimate the power
of an image like that and especially in
the age of social media for it to get
around and for them to try to make it
stick of course yeah and in fact senator
Kamala Harris has already tweeted out
saying if he can't shake the hand of a
victim of gun violence why can't how can
we be sure that victims will have a say
in the court listen as you see in the
video it's even slowed down it's only a
second law the still image is is
obviously right there but it had been a
morning full of protests and let's not
forget that this is a Supreme Court
nominee who now has a lot of security
and it is you know it's a precarious
time and he doesn't know who's walking
up from the outside so it lasts a second
I think that there will be a lot made of
it but in context it's it's a different
story Dana Katie Pavlich here good to
see you watching you all day when the
hearing wasn't on can you talk again
about the character witnesses I think
there's been a lot of attention paid to
what Democrats were doing today some of
the things that they're saying some of
the smears that they lobbed toward this
nominee Kamala Harris essentially
accusing Brett Kavanaugh of being racist
and not applying the law equally and
fairly depending on who he was who was
in front of him in terms of his
decisions he had Lisa Blatt who's a
self-described feminist attorney on the
left talking about her experience with
him yet Condoleezza Rice who you worked
with saying that she hands-down could
vouch for his character and his
integrity and saying that he seeks truth
and facts so you just talk a little bit
about how important those statements
were that came at the end of the day and
well I think that it was such a contrast
to what you saw earlier in the day with
the Senators right so when you have
finally you get the non politicians
there to just say hey I
here to introduce somebody that I know
and then I care about and that I believe
in and you can take it from me or not
but this is what I believe those are
very credible people that have come with
a lot of integrity and decency so I
think that that helps a lot there's a
few other things
remember the ABA which is pretty lovely
knee and the American excuse me the the
lawyers association gave him a
well-qualified rating that's their
highest rating but also if you look at
his decisions over the past twelve years
on the DC Circuit Court his colleagues
both Democrats and Republicans have been
appointed for those lifetime
appointments they voted with him and
sided with him about 90% of the time on
average so that says to me that he's
ruled for and against Republicans and
Democrats and that he just looks at the
law and in his opening statement he said
the same so you know I'm watching so I
think you guys are making so many
excuses for this nominee but the fact is
even as well well I mean it's incredible
to me that the Republicans dumped forty
two thousand documents the night before
a hearing and you guys don't say well
you know that's not fair you know now
who can read forty two thousand
documents overnight they're not gonna
read oh that's just beyond the like
Obama say Obama care memorable thing was
as you say not not only that he snubbed
the guy and by not shaking his hand but
then you had these women in the back
dress like Handmaid's Tale and they're
saying memorable things that was one of
the most memorable things to me because
what I'm saying is if you look at the
issues here you look at a guy who is a
political activist not only working in
the bush White House but working with
Ken Starr on the Clinton impeachment
coming right after President Trump is
attacking Jeff Sessions in the Justice
Department and here's a guy who has said
I'm not sure we can bother the president
with any criminal or civil matter while
he's like so maybe we should leave below
you don't mention this nice to tell you
something the American people are asked
right now about this and I'll put this
to you both you see that there is less
support for this Republican nominee than
there was for Gorsuch I mean it's
unbelievable why is there only
31 to 38 people say he shouldn't be
confirmed yeah two answers one is I
think a lot of the people polled so far
haven't known him or met him heard from
him today his opening statement was
probably the first time that they had
heard from judge Cavanaugh - you're
right the 42 thousand is a legitimate
question but they didn't have to ask
questions today the questioning is
tomorrow so they have 24 more hours to
look at the 42,000 documents and they
can ask a lot of questions based on that
it is it was released by the National
Archives at last night and three is that
listen the votes are not there and so
when you look at 307 opinions judge
Cavanaugh said read the opinion that is
the judge I am and even praised Merrick
garland in his opening statement can I
jump in here real quick because why
brought up a good point the handmade
tale character this is suggesting that
if you if if Cavanaugh makes it America
is gonna become a dystopian disaster
filled with misogyny and and forced
pregnancies and brutality against all
women the old Democratic Party would
have seen that as hyperbole now it's
just meat and potatoes this is exactly
what they believe this is what happened
with when Brett mentioned the pork
it started with pork and it's just
gotten worse every time when Republicans
put forth a nominee it's it's a tense
circuit